[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
obésité l'autre pandémique
la pandémie de qu'ovide 19 ne doit pas
en faire oublier une autre le surpoids
et l'obésité qui figure parmi les
premières comorbidités associées au
virus
en 2016 près de 2 milliards d'adultes
étaient en surpoids et sur ce total plus
de 650 millions étaient obèses soit 13 %
de la population mondiale
en france un adulte sur deux est en
surpoids et 17 % sont obèses
dans le rapport adopté le 29 juin 2022
par la commission des affaires
économiques les sénatrices chantal de
scène brigitte deveza et michel meunier
font observer que l'autonomie des
individus dans le changement de leur
comportement alimentaire est limitée
c'est pourquoi elle estime indispensable
plutôt que de miser exclusivement sur la
responsabilisation des individus de
promouvoir des mesures favorables à la
santé est de réunir pour tous les
conditions d'un environnement plus sain
le gradient social de la maladie est
particulièrement élevé 75 % des enfants
en surpoids ou en obésité sont issus des
catégories populaires et inactive les
enfants d'ouvriers sont quatre fois plus
touchées par l'obésité que les enfants
de cadres constatent les rapporteurs
l'action publique en matière de
nutrition santé doit donc encore se
structurer et se renforcer
les sénateurs propose d'expérimenter la
distribution de chèques alimentation
ciblées sur les ménages les plus
précaires
en matière de prévention les rapporteurs
recommandent d'éduquer précocement à
l'alimentation et à la cuisine
en 2013 87% des 910 enfants interrogés
en paca par un réseau de 2500 médecins
ignoraient ce qu est une betterave sur
le plan du contrôle et de la régulation
il paraît indispensable d'encadrer
strictement la publicité visant les
enfants à la télévision ainsi que le
marketing agressif en faveur d' aliments
trop gras ou trop sucrés
la commission suggère de s'inspirer de
mesures prises par d'autres pays comme
au royaume uni où les promotions
commerciales en grande distribution sur
une liste de produits trop sucrés salés
ou gras sont interdites ou encore le
chili où les dispositifs marketing
ludiques visant à capter l'attention des
enfants sont désormais prohibés
les auteurs du rapport appellent par
ailleurs à faire évoluer l'algorithme et
l'affichage du nutrisse corps pour mieux
prendre en compte les aliments ultra
transformé
elle demande aussi une régulation de
l'installation des nouveaux restaurants
de restauration rapide à proximité des
écoles collèges et lycées
parallèlement les rapporteurs
préconisent de rendre accessible
l'activité physique et sportive sur tout
le territoire par des engagements au
sein des contrats locaux de santé
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport
[Musique]